les conseils du jour a bien ça va
concerner la météo pied en effet on se
pose souvent des questions est-ce qu'il
faut courir quand il fait très chaud
mais la réponse est non pourquoi
mais déjà parce que vous allez perdre
énormément d'eau vous allez vous
hydrater là vous risquez de faire des
malaises
ensuite c'est vraiment extrêmement
mauvais pour tout votre système cardio
respiratoire et puis plus il fait chaud
plus la pollution est intense donc on ne
court pas quand il fait très chaud
ensuite est ce qu'il fait courir il faut
courir quand il fait froid et bien
jusqu'à 2,3 degrés oui on peut courir en
dessous non là aussi ça pose un problème
pour les bronches et vous risquez
d'avoir des problèmes de faire des
malaises aussi donc on ne sort pas quand
il fait très chaud et quand il fait très
froid est-ce qu'il faut courir sous la
pluie
pourquoi pas alors faut être un peu fou
pour courir quand il ya une pluie
diluvienne
donc on reste à la maison quand y'a une
pluie fine mais écoutez ça peut être
salvateur on peut avoir l'impression de
faire une douche à l'extérieur aucun
problème pour cela en tout cas quand
vous sortez et qu'il pleut pensez à vous
couvrir c'est important tout simplement
parce que sinon vous risquez le
refroidissement à bientôt pour un
prochain conseil
running